so imagine the following scenario you're
a med student or Michael doctor in real
life in hospital of 2 a.m. and you're on
call to require even know who's around
and suddenly there's a code which is
called you know code blue you rush into
the room and there's half a dozen people
you only know a couple of their names
and you have to figure out what do you
do next you know do you remember what
the appropriate drug to inject is and do
you remember the right Jules set on the
defibrillator another kind of high
impacts domain which has these
life-or-death situations this aviation
so in aviation you also have teams with
people working in these tasks which take
perhaps a long time and just as an
aviation so you sometimes have hours of
boredom punctuated by moments of sheer
terror and so aviation and medicine have
this kind of similar component of having
really complex perilous procedures we're
really trained professionals have to
cope and really fast time to dance and
in aviation one of the tools they use to
manage this complexity is checklists so
for several decades now it's been very
standard to use checklists drink routine
operations and during crises so when
you're taking off you pull out the
checklists when you're about to crash
into the river you also take out the
checklists doesn't really matter so in
contrast then medicine the use of
checklists hasn't been as widely
distributed or used and something we're
only now our checklists starting to be
used much more commonly during both
routine care and in crisis care so two
local one day is one of the people that
has kind of popularized and kind of
Britain really cogently about the
importance of checklists and medicine
and here's some example of one of the
checklists that has been well studied in
terms of helping people to do better
search freeze so it has very simple
things such as before you start the
surgery do you do a timeout is it the
right patients it's the right procedure
is it the right side and then you go
through all these pre-surgical safety
timeouts
but similar checklists have actually
been shown to make big differences in
outcomes so intended trials looking at
central lines it drastically changes
infection rates and in other multi-site
trials you can really change lies and
save lots of money but in contrast
medicine is still kind of evolving as
the fields unlike in aviation there's no
kind of central body which records all
medical errors and records everything
which happens so this is an example of
what you might see in the hospital oh
are where doctors may just kind of go
and write down some of these information
by hands that may help them during their
tasks here's a more formalized version
which they use a Stanford so if you're
at a institution like Stanford or
Harvard Medical School you'll be trained
in the use of these checklists and they
call them more broadly cognitive aids
during your training so this particular
cotton evade addresses the condition of
pulseless electrical activity and kind
of walks you through things you should
check and make sure you don't miss as
well as things that you should think
about during the treatment protocol so
how do these cloud navigates help when
they do help so we think about it
they're an aid to not only memory but
attention so oftentimes if you're called
into the code perhaps you haven't done
this procedure in a month or a year this
actual procedures which most doctors
don't see in their lifetimes and are you
going to remember the right procedures
that you want to do from your medical
training so besides memory it's also an
attention aid you know are you attending
to the right things in this right moment
so we know that during stress your
attention narrows and your cognitive
processes get more limited and so these
external kada develops cognitive aids
essentially put knowledge into the world
rather than keeping them in your brain
the ourselves was training so they kind
of define these mental schema so that
both novices and experts can kind of go
back and refer to them and keep up to
date with what changes in medicine and
one might argue that's
aids may help teams maintain a shared
mental model you know if you pull out
the aid do you know what were procedure
we're doing are you on the kind of same
page it's been shown in aviation that
shared mental models can increase team
performance and finally when you talk
about individual performance one doctor
said that you really want these aids to
raise up level of these lowest
performers so maybe people who are less
experienced or are working on something
which is not their specialty you want to
kind of raise these people up to the
average so as part of our design process
we spend some time observing this and as
she's the crisis resource management
class so this is adapted from aviation
where they have these crisis management
classes or copying resource management
classes so they teach people the kind of
soft skills or non-technical skills that
they used to work together resentful how
do you delegate and work as a team how
do you anticipate in distributed
workload how do you allocate your
attention and use all the resources that
you have available so in this project we
focus specifically on the attentional
aspects and on these resources aspects
so these kind of card ended aids are
just one of the resources that doctors
can call upon as they're solving
problems so do your medical training
maybe you're sitting in lks see across
the street kind of paying attention in
lecture as you guys have done but an
important part of their training is not
just in lecture butts in more realistic
situations so this is an aviation people
will train on simulation for many hours
before they graduate medical doctors are
storage starting to train more and
medical simulations these are high
fidelity medical simulators where
doctors actually go in and practice
skills such as you know how do you pay
attention and keep act all these tests
which are going on in a busy scenario so
picture here is actually a simulator in
the basement of the lake hushing
building across the streets and you have
people participating in these kind of
simulated emergencies you have these
really fantastic and comprehensive
medical simulators where everything is
real
except the patients you have the gases
you have drugs yo vials you have all
these things which you can operate on
but the patient is obviously a mannequin
and the mannequin can talk it can shake
it can you know admit various bodily
fluids at certain points in time so
basically you kind of forget that you're
working with this this kind of fake
Asian but behind the scenes there is a
kind of Dungeon Master's or people
controlling the situation remove them
from behind the scenario and here you
have David gala who's actually an
anesthesiologist here who pioneered
high-fidelity simulation in anesthesia
25 years ago and so here he's kind of
watching what's going on these are
probably residents who are going through
some training and there's a pre-scripted
scenario you know what monsters will you
run and see you and what will happen so
they'll be controlling the patient kind
of changing their their life vital signs
and kind of directing sometimes the
voice of God will say certain things
like you know the last like I was just
going in a certain way and then if the
simulator doesn't support that the voice
of God will say yes you feel something
that is lumpy or something so it
provides for human-computer interaction
researchers this great opportunity to
not only observe in situations where you
don't have to deal with HIPAA concerns
with privacy and also you can kind of
intervene so in HCI you talk about
Wizard of Oz where someone can kind of
control behind the scenes and hiss
provides a really great opportunity for
kind of amazing wizard of oz scenarios
so Jesse now I spent you know year and a
half kind of observing lots of these
different and as she's our courses so we
watched dozens of doctors kind of go
through many of these scenarios watching
from safely behind the one-way mirror so
for example we watched the same patient
died in the same way half a dozen times
from the same exact thing but we saw
half a dozen doctors treat that patient
very differently in terms of how they
diagnosed that patient have a delegated
amongst the team did they ask people for
heads help in addition to hands help did
they communicate effectively with other
people in the room for example
they stew can you get me the crash car
versus and thin air communication such
as I need a crash cart so in terms of
other individual errors we notice that
people would often be blind to certain
changes in the environments they
wouldn't see that the patient had got
into you know VT and so when person one
person noticed it and fed it to the
other they actually didn't make that
successful communication so so one
doctor would say oh the patients in VT
and the other doctor just didn't realize
that wasn't paying attention sometimes
you just get the diagnosis wrong so
practice a condition which most doctors
don't see in their lifetimes and they
think it's something which is much more
common sometimes they get the algorithms
wrong so perhaps they you know shock and
then check for the pulse instead of
doing CPR immediately or perhaps they're
compressing too slowly or not deep
enough and whether we also notice is
that they lose time and they just do
things late slashing one of the
scenarios we watched for this condition
which isn't that common when the doctors
actually pulled out their iPhone and
started looking up on some medical
database what was going on and as you
through them you know on the order of
minutes rather than seconds to refer
this database so this is something which
it can hopefully be improved upon so in
terms of what we do as technologists or
as human computer interaction
specialists we thought a lot about how
might we do better you know in what ways
can you understand these existing work
processes and use technology to make
these processes better so we thought if
I might we improve the adoption of the
checklists and aids so you do we watch
thousands of doctors go through these
scenarios but even though they were
trained in the residency by this
specific anesthesiologist to use cotton
evades you know not everyone uses these
aids and practice so maybe only half of
them pull it out part of the time and
it's something where you know depending
on the institution depending on the
person they may choose to use it or not
use it there's lots of different social
factors do they
appear that they're losing authority for
example when they pull out these aids so
something where perhaps technology can
help so something we haven't studied yet
specifically but maybe a factors that's
you know do you appear more
authoritative if you pull out a tablet
versus a paper display which some of our
interviews may suggests how might you
make these eid is really easy to access
so we watch doctors as they were going
through these crises and sometimes they
would pull out the AIDS but then they
would put them down and so people have
observed you know you put the AIDS down
you put other things on top of it you
know you put it you kind of hold it in
one hand it's something we're just
having this paper is not a very kind of
usable form factor for this really
complex environments how can you have to
design these aids to be quickly
assimilated so in these crises you don't
have very much time and you want to make
them so that you can actually absorb the
information so the analogy from kind of
mobile interaction is how do you get
driving directions so back in the day
you just get you know mapquest
step-by-step directions but now with GPS
neither knows where you are it can give
you turn-by-turn and it turns out that
in our research you can actually spend
less time looking at what the next step
is because it's more contextualized and
this is also an area where lots of
different design comes into play for
example special possibly using the aid
can be broken down into the visual cost
of finding the aid and parsing it then
the cognitive cost of understanding it
and some of the interaction costs so if
you can kind of change these cost
structures perhaps you can make it more
common for doctors to actually pull out
and then absorb this information and
then finally you have these situations
where the doctors don't have much time
or attention can you actually engineer
the interaction and the design so it
works under these limited time frames
welcome some situational in control at
the moment is there a reason why that
would need to be the case might not have
someone else in the room
responsible for tracking whether or not
you're sticking with scripts that's a
really question so an aviation you have
co-pilots where they have a very
standardized routine for kind of do
check protocols so during takeoff the
pilot goal or the copilot may say you
know writers check you know a laura and
check or whatever and in medicine it's
more complicated because you have much
more complicated team dynamics so
medicine unlike aviation you have all
these people with very different
training and cultures so nurses and
doctors and even different specialties
and so in terms of who actually gets to
own the aid had does determine kind of
social factors so for example people
have researched what happens if you
introduce this reader role where our
residents or doctor starts saying like
five minutes of the code this day will
you know here's a piece of paper it
might be useful and then ten minutes in
the code Sao like this is a paper
relevant to this specific scenario I'm
going to read it out loud and so turns
out that people have studied these two
these readers and codes and it's a
useful effective thing but then it's a
question of who gets the authority so
like if you're reading what should be
done are you then directing what needs
to be done and so that's probably why
perhaps these beauty rules have not been
widely adopted yet it's because there's
no clear standard of you know who
actually reads these aids who's in power
and how they accessed so I think it's
it's a very interesting question which
also affects our design so I'll talk a
little bit later about how we design the
system so that doctors still felt in
control even though other people may be
helping out with them so we do a pretty
long design process we had the help of
water undergraduates over the course of
two summers working on this so in the
first summer after kind of watching
these anesthesiologists we can i started
this design port of having process and
so picking up these prototypes as a kind
of conversation with the doctors so we'd
you know build prototypes kind of
non-interactive kind of sketchy ones
with paper or keynote
and then in a week-by-week basis we go
and kind of get their feedback and kind
of walk through these things so
sometimes we go into the simulator and
do these kind of design charrette sand
say okay you're in this booger scenario
here is the technological version of
your existing paper aids no is this
actually useful so as part of this kind
of prototyping loop it's sort of this
design build and then kind of simulating
loop which I think which I kind of hope
will kind of affect how medical research
is done so just this past year the first
paper using a high fidelity medical
simulation was published in the New
England Journal of Medicine which is a
pretty big deal so for a long time
people haven't used kind of simulations
to inform how doctors practice but now
that this paper was published looking at
specifically checklist and cognitive
aids hopefully more doctors will kind of
investigate simulation and as
technologists it provides us a great
opportunity to get in there and I should
iterate and try things out at a much
lower costs so instead of going to a
hospital and having to deal with all the
privacy concerns and having to watch
videos and delete them total hours later
has just the practice you can actually
kind of go this loop and a much faster
faster way so this is a bit about how
the ORS are set up so we observed mainly
anesthesiologist residents working in
the o.r cyrus works is that the
anesthesiologist is in charge of
perioperative patient care so let's say
a surgeon is doing things they're
probably in control but a sling goes
wrong like the plane starts going down
is kind of analogy the anesthesiologist
is kind of like the pilot so they're in
charge of like takeoff and landing and
if something goes wrong so let's say you
know the patient starts hemorrhaging or
the patients patients heart becomes
tachycardic yeah she geologists usually
use the one that step in and kind of
takes control of this situation so the
MSU geologist on the right let's say
she's kind of looking at the patient
from the top of the head of the display
so it's part of our process we built
our interactive systems for these
cognitive aids so that they can be used
for multiple perspectives so to address
this issue of access we both displays
which were not only on large screens but
not to dine cards which would come in
and so this is kind of like a stadium
display we're here in a stadium you can
see with action from wherever things are
going on but you guys who gives you this
idea of the kind of complexity of this
environments I think as an HR researcher
it's really interesting field because in
comparison to office work you have you
know you may even have a dozen people in
a complex cardiac code that have very
different training that are trying to do
multiple things in the same co-located
situation so it gets really complex in
the number of devices and number of
people in these environments so after
our design process this is kind of what
we came up with in terms of the some of
the form factors so we experimented with
putting stuff on the wall the
disadvantage of that is that's you know
doctors weren't always looking at the
wall there often kind of going back and
forth between the patient fields and the
vitals display / anesthesia machine ends
some of the drug carts so instead we
tried mounting the displays on this
crash cart so if doctors call a code
blue and 0 are or in the hospital then
nurses will bring in this crash cart
which has the different letters and
epinephrine so we just put this large
display in there and I also provided
this kind of tablet interaction this is
one of the doctors looking at it so we
designed this system and we built it so
that it could be accessed from local
places in their room so because we had
multiple displays we then synchronize
the interaction across the displays
using web sockets for these really low
latency synchronization so to address
some of these concerns of you who gets
in control because ever you can see it
and in theory everyone can control it
but in our system we're trying to
encourage people to use the tablets to
control it this method so that the
doctors feel that they're in control
I'll talk a little bit more about this
but the ideas that's we're essentially
giving doctors in charge kind of
voice command interface into this so
that they can tell the nurse or the
technician or they even that other
doctor that's controlled tablet you know
can you bring up the aid for malignant
hypothermia so okay we deploy this and
the simulator so that's just me and I
got the foot on scrubs and operate the
system in simulation and some of the
things we learn from actually putting it
in the simulator and trying it out with
anesthesia residents was that really
admitted to make it always ready so
doctors wouldn't use it if they had to
spend a lot of time configuring and
saying it up so the idea is if it's it's
still useful before the crisis happens
perhaps though can I keep on using it so
because the doctors were often busy we
gave the nurse or in this case I was
going to technician its primary control
which is synchronized and finally we
have this kind of big display so as part
of this design process one of the kind
of unexpected insights was this kind of
shift from thinking of it as a cognitive
aid to something which is more enticing
to doctors so if you think about what
doctors want they want to access and
manage the resources and that includes
their time but it also includes
information and people so you'll see
later in some of the design of the
systems but we design it so that they
would think of his system as a way to
access resources which are useful to
them and that would hopefully
incentivize them to use it so we we did
back off from making it kind of a
step-by-step checklist so when you think
of checklist you often think of
something where you need to execute
every step in lockstep border but one
thing we noticed was that when doctors
use these aids use them in kind of a
nonlinear fashion so sometimes they
would pick it up and skim it sometimes
they would kind of huddle together and
try to determine something that was
going on and sometimes they'd be kind of
Hail Mary where doctors were just you
know kind of go through things at the
last minute because they're not sure
what's going on so we tried to make it
so as more flexible as a system and so
think of it as an aid to some broadly we
incorporate
Quest's into the system but they were
just one resource that people call upon
and something where they didn't have to
click things step by step to go to the
next step so in terms of you know
putting this in the simulator one thing
we realize quickly is that doctors don't
have very much time and so a lot of our
earlier prototypes were a lot more
complicated so this is kind of Midway
long essay because i'll show that later
so if you actually look at where do
doctors look in some of these
simulations we mounted a head mounted
camera on one of the anesthesiologist
and kind of track you know where they
were were is this him of the camera
looking as a proxy for their gaze and
attention and we went and kind of coded
what they were doing and what they were
looking at and kind of look at you know
this is like six minutes and so it's
something where they're kind of looking
back and forth not necessary spending
very much time looking at a single thing
and this is something where they would
kind of be going back and forth between
these different items but the takeaway
is that if you actually plot these gays
lengths and kind of sort them to get a
sense of how the doctors spend their
time in some of these crises so most of
these gays times are actually pretty
short so a lot of times are less than
five or six seconds so this is actually
kind of supported by other research in
the field where people have looked at
you know how often do doctors look at
vital sign monitors so most their looks
are less than I guess three seconds in
this case other people were looking at
how much and displays and they said how
much they spend looking at these
workstations that so anesthesiologist
will look at these relations to trim in
like how drugs are getting infused and
so on so again it's like about 3.7
seconds in a clearly unrelated field
people with their mobile each shy and
said oh you have these kind of four
second interaction purse so something
about kind of this number where whether
you're in a hurry or you're a doctor you
will not really want to design for these
kind of short and a bursty thing which
is not what we expected I also goes back
to the kind of checklist approach if
you're only going to be looking at at
four second bursts it's not necessarily
a checklist in a sense that you're going
to go through it and spend like a minute
so this is one of our earlier designs
you can say it's a bit busier has me
more color we're experimenting with some
of the point of the vital signs in the
lower left to kind of draw their I we
explored a lot of a kind of timeline and
giving doctors information about what
has happened in the past on the left so
for example if we could automatically
track drug injections and vital signs we
could track that and provide that the
doctors and say you know now you're
doing this we also had information about
you know supplies is some of the you
know EMR sort of things we're giving
them information about the patient one
thing that the doctors actually
suggested and really lights was you can
look in the top right there's actually
information about people in the room so
if you're in a small Hospital maybe you
know everyone who's on your code team
but oftentimes your call to the code and
you don't necessarily know everyone on
your shifts so actually turns out that
doctors really like this idea of you
know seeing who's in the room so you can
use for example smart name badges and
people have done some research and
studying these things to provide
information about you know who's in the
room and what are they doing so if your
comment coming to a code situation you
know someone is going into cardiac
arrest in hospital wing it offers will
kind of rush in there and they're
getting pages in but they don't know
like who's the patients they send like
in turn to run for the medical documents
and then they don't know is there a
cardiologist here can they get a cardio
consult so it's really really messy so
it was something where you can
automatically service this information
about who's in the room and what can I
do but not only that you know some of
the prototypes explore this notion of
leadership can you specify this person
is a team leader so in fact as some
people now put on hats or coats or stand
on something of a taller to signify that
they are the leader because it kind of
simplifies how this works but going back
to the tension piece you know there's a
lot of stuff going on here and as we
iterated we kind of started realizing
that the doctors wanted to see what was
going on right now and so we started our
focus into something that's much more
like turn-by-turn so like as you're
driving it only tells you what you need
to do now and so in this interface
they'll say okay now
you're going to differently 20 joules
like what has happened in the past
what's going to happen in the future you
can look at it later but we're just
trying to focus their attention and here
you have the team lead and ass back and
it's a little more desaturated to not
use colors you don't have to so in terms
of thinking about this we're thinking of
this not just the cognitive eight but
this kind of more dynamic kind of
procedural aid so it is something where
it's dynamic because the system can
perhaps infer what's going on or perhaps
other doctors can say you know we're at
this point in the treatment step and so
everyone is on the same page and they
don't have to spend time looking for
this information so i'ma show you a
video of how this mask you work in
practice so in this version the doctor
is actually using the tablet themselves
but we've also experimented with this
condition where someone else is using it
I'm just for this video it turned out it
looked better if they were using it but
this is kind of a simulated code where
they're making use of this stable system
and this one you don't have the large
screen display on the wall but this is
basically investigating what happens if
you put the displays on the crash cart
and make this sort of crash cart 2 point
0 so always busy nocona tote it off yeah
are you can turn it is really I just
nice to start out he was protocol it
look away the titration tedious piecing
you didn't work have you given up an
open yet we just gave them down of
epinephrine yeah okay yeah we took about
10 reader to resume tell you gonna test
you as you down the rhythm check oh yes
that's the guys just at PCC others who
can do a ribbon check okay i was taking
Triple fibrillation power to raise a
defibrillation the game times you can't
a profession all right happy senior mass
ventilation continue CPR so I'm not
going to gives you a sedative how
frantic it might be the music is kind of
obviously intended for can be very very
kind of energy but turns out you know
hovering rooms are really noisy so
people are using playing music if it's
the surgeon will put on whatever kind of
jelly Billy Joel that he likes and
usually they turned off when twice
happens but you know this always seems
beeping people or talk to each other all
these noises it's something where if you
think about it from the interaction
perspective one reason we didn't do
audio is because it is an overloaded
channel but this kind of gives you a
sense of you know how some of the design
challenges and kind of interaction
challenges of having multiple displays
and multiple people and this kind of
multi surface design environments so
welcome through just these are just some
of the kind of aspects of the system so
by making a dynamic we're only focusing
their information on what they need to
do now so here they need to do CPR you
know a specific rate and frequency and I
see turns out people do really bad CPR
so most people don't compress at heart
beats per minute and say if you actually
track like Bueller trains they actually
spend a lot of time not compressing so
this is something where if you can track
these things and have it be part of the
aid know if we can improve adherence get
it again this large screen display and
something that we haven't studied yet in
terms of those
display actually increase the shared
mental model and then performance but
perhaps in future studies we can study
how does this impact performance and
then finally this kind of mirror display
where you can kind of separate the
interaction so someone the Commission
can operate it or the doctor can operate
it and the team can benefit from all the
information so just going to summing up
the high level approach of this design
is that we built it for ready access so
there sir displays it's always on it's
not something that you just pull out in
the case of only emergencies we designed
it to be quickly assimilated so I won't
go into some of the design work that
goes into compression text in the visual
design but basically you can make these
kind of stereotype structures or design
it so that information can be parsed
really quickly without as much texts and
then third acceptance so really focusing
on how can you design it so that's you
can incentivize people to access these
resources at a glance and then finally
attention so focusing information having
this dynamic interface I'm going to walk
through some of the just an example
dynamic age is to show what the
interface that we design look like so
again you see in the top rights that
people in the room on their roles you
can access services or help you know we
want to call for a car a crash cart EKG
on the bottom right the patient
information on the left you have this is
some of the A's that we were initially
implementing so we focused on what they
call advanced cardiac life support which
basically all doctors receive training
in usually in their last year's of their
medical school and they get retrained on
a regular basis so this is what happens
if someone has cardiac arrests there you
know pulse becomes really fast or
erratic so you provide some information
sent by showing some of the rhythm so
that people can kind of match the
rhythms so let's say you in this
condition they click on v-tach and they
go on
or v-fib so again we're showing this
visual information sense we're showing
some of the important things in terms of
compressions and depth showing the
rotating compressors good turns out
people get tired and their compression
gets worse and then the situation
progresses they need to defibrillate 200
joules and then museum CPR immediately
and then some of the advantages of
software are once you defibrillate into
CPR you can then have automated drug
timers so because you may lose track of
time if you can then either sense it or
manually input it you can have these
timers so the question becomes you know
this is real interesting design were
kind of observation and understanding
domain but this is actually work can you
actually show that certain design
choices or certain implementations or
certain aspects in the environment is it
is it actually feasible to have doctors
use technological aids and because it's
not yet come and practice these
technological aids we kind of wanted to
understand the kind of usability and
those are aspects for a system work and
weather challenges becomes you know how
do you rapidly get feedback on these
approaches so observing the simulation
is something we could do very cheaply
but actually intervening is pretty
expensive so if you think about all the
people time the space-time be able to do
these kind of randomized controlled
trials that's really expensive in terms
of renting out the space and the med
school so we started looking at more
kind of engineering level or kind of
really fast tests of understanding
what's hi doctors actually use these
interfaces under stress so here's I'm
not gonna go into detail about the study
design but we use this kind of screen
based simulators as part of this
immediately thought a medium fidelity
simulation approach so in low fidelity
simulation you often use just screens by
themselves and you have dr. sit down and
just use them so it turns out that that
is useful in understanding and be able
to teach lockers but it when it comes to
some of these non-technical skills like
communication management using cognitive
aids just having one screen doesn't work
so weeks
I need this to this multi-screen kind of
medium fidelity approach so we do is we
designed a scenario which would advance
in lockstep with our interface so it
wouldn't branch at all and one of the
manage of this is that it's a very low
cost thing to do so you have these
parallel screenshots essentially
advancing and you have the doctors
respond to these situations in real time
so doctors will have to answer questions
like you know what is your next step or
how should you dose epinephrine or like
how often should you do sit here we had
a there's a simulated patient which
wasn't there an actual study and the
patient who is here the doctor was kind
of looking at the screen also taking
care of the secondary task so there's a
lot more to the study but I can go into
what the takeaways were and the basic
takeaway is that we looked at how much
did people deviate from the protocol so
we had our medical doctors kind of
define the kind of correct answers and
the correct protocol and then we went
through and kind of coded responses
based on do they follow this protocol so
in a sense this overestimates the sum of
the errors or perhaps it's a different
class others so for example certain
drugs so doctors have specific
preferences about you know what drugs
they'd like to use or not use even
though the protocol says you know use
you know drug acts some doctors say well
you know I don't really like the
effectiveness of that so some of these
errors are kind of that noise the people
have their own specific preferences some
of these errors are just they didn't
respond to the questions in time so even
though we are them 10 seconds about and
so even though some of the decisions you
can wait for longer than 10 seconds we
marked it as an error if they just
didn't respond within the time frame um
c fabrica de is me kind of a closer
third was mark as an error of these
responses so we had kind of ten minute
long scenarios
um and we had design land square design
where the three conditions were having
no aid being unaided being exposed to
paper aids which they have had work
they've had training using different day
parades but nice i like these aids and
then our kind of software based dates so
for the paper aids we use the existing
paper aids he's actually the ones that
were studied both in that bill England
Journal of Medicine paper and some other
papers where they shown that teams of
crisis responders do better when you
code them based on their performance if
you give them aids versus unaided so in
this situation we dimmed aids we didn't
mandate their use because that seemed
more realistic but it turns out in our
study that there wasn't very much
difference between the people that
receive the paper aids and the people
that were on ID'd and some of that maybe
that's they weren't trained enough on
these aids so people often reported you
know I'm used to the American Heart
Association kind of style of aids so
they have a certain mental model of how
they think about the kind of you know
CPR dosed epinephrine no check loop and
they think of a specific flow chart
which is in the H a bore is in these
aids maybe it's expressed in text or
maybe the guidelines are slightly
different so it may be that's if people
receive more training or the time
constraints weren't as severe presumably
people would do better with the paper
rains but that's not we found in our
limited study again so we about 30
participants looked at medical students
residents fellows and when we compared
it with a condition where they had our
dynamic aid data quite a bit better so
again these aren't necessarily
significant medical errors so that was a
fully smaller fraction of these so in
terms of what errors were actually are
going to Regis versus what is something
where
you you know you pulse check instead of
doing a no-call like a rhythm check
whistling so um kind of just wrapping up
kind of describe some of our design work
some of our engineering implementation
work and kind of building out the system
and trying it out and then they kind of
briefly touched upon some of the
experimental results so Jesse who's
going to be talking later this quarter
will do a much deeper dive into this
study and also a newer study which we've
done looking at kind of timing and gaze
but here I'll just talk about kind of
summarizing what we found and also just
talking about what's the vision of this
project was so how this project started
was Larry chief of anesthesiology came
to us and kind of gave a talk at the shy
group and was kinda excited about this
idea of making card in the dates born
interactive and because it is a kind of
fairly new research area in medicine
that's something where we thought and as
technologists can we intervene kind of
speed the adoption of this technology
can we kind of escape regeneration and
make aids easier to use but also get
them distributed across the world so
something with paper aids the
publication cycles are really long it's
hard to access it's something where you
know it with visual distribution you got
obviously hoping you a lot better so
this is kind of a vision of where this
project might be going so here's a
simulated operation you have someone
doing CPR in the back you can have the
simulated wall screen display maybe
we'll even take up a whole wall and then
incomes are a crash cart 2 point 0 so
this has the kind of mounted display on
it it has the power interface something
where doctors can kind of as they're
accessing these kind of drug resources
they can call upon you know medical
information they can see perhaps can you
show me show me the ultrasound or show
me the patient history do this person
have history of you know kidneys gallery
or something and then again kind of the
tablet display something which isn't
necessarily clear is all these
factors how doctors actually use them so
do they prefer kind of smaller handheld
displays or will they be more likely to
use kind of phone sighs displays so
something we're hoping to experiment
with over the summer is kind of you know
even the next step so maybe you've seen
people walking around not in view with
these glasses I don't have it's a little
freaky but here there so can you do
something like this guy over here and
you know what's next after the
stethoscope can you provide information
to doctors kind of on demands and I'm
going to just briefly show the previous
video and kind of this vision format of
how so here's what it might look like if
you know if we had a glass which we like
TBA it's again it's something we're
using this information you can get
information about you know who's in the
room but because it's on to the glass
you know you don't have to look away
they access it again that's something
where you know when you go into the room
you don't have to you know send people
off to get the information display I'll
just turn out the volume and you can
just access it based on you know
information that's in the room so
whether you're in a no are or hospital
wing you can get that information and
again again this is where some of the
interactive this is some this is where
some of the interactivity comes in so if
you can for example sense compressions
either using devices so some people have
belts I phone-based compression tools
which will sense using accelerometers or
if you can sense using auditory or
visual sensing you can then get a sense
of four
stuff how often and how quickly people
are ventilating so it's actually very
common for people to over ventilate
which is bad and for people to undress
which is also bad and so these things
seem very simple but if you can then
sense them and provide feedback to the
team leader in this case you can you
know hopefully make a difference and
then finally besides resources you can
also access kind of this dynamic eight
information about the protocol so you
know what should you now something where
you can kind of make sure you're on the
right track and then ok ok save the
vision
actually like automatically put the
right information on me such a small
display our first approach will just to
use people power and because it's
synchronized oftentimes those already of
recorder role so a nurse is already
recording what gets injected when so
you're saying okay I did epinephrine at
342 and the doctor will ask how long
since last epinephrine and the nurse
will say oh it's been three minutes it's
okay to read us so something where there
are actually our roles already for data
entry so we imagine that's the first
approach would be to have these and
other people in the room access the
information um people talk a lot about
kind of AI but actually I think what
will happen before AI is the role of the
crowd and kind of remote work in medical
hospitals so because the cost of having
doctors actually here is so high you can
imagine for example if you were remotes
you actually may be able to provide
better feedback so it turns out if
you're standing outside the o.r
situation looking in you know things
seem very calm whereas people inside
they don't always appear calm and when
they come out they talk about how you
know it seemed more stressful so it's
something we're with you know crowd work
fuku for example have a platform for
secure card work where doctors could
then help out it's something where they
could kind of direct things so it's kind
of analogous to the air traffic
controller where someone is kind of
watching and then directing and so
perhaps that would also help with having
doctors not stay up all the time and so
on and then obviously finally the next
step would be both ubicomp sensing and
kind of inference based on that so if
you can then instruments all these
devices you can get a sense of what's
going on and then do kind of prediction
based on you know if someone injected
dopamine then they're probably giving in
the fusion and if the EKG rhythm is
you know a certain is like tachycardic
then perhaps is more likely that this
aid is more common and so you can
suggest consider you know this other
infusion at this rate instead I noticed
that you were accusing at 10x what you
should be doing so let's answer your
question this dynamic cognitive aids
would be really helpful accessible let's
just say large screen you know they they
can be sequential and follow the
protocol the time but to the extent that
you have interactive checklists as part
of the cognitive aid have you looked
into the error rate for data entry in a
very high-stress time so yeah the doctor
says in verse with into that because
what does it well now I gotta treat the
patient you know is that without the
world's designated day the eight-footer
and then even with one um you know as he
was saying error rates in self reports
and an input it seems like you know you
might be generating other kinds of
errors with dynamic checklist sister I
think with respect to infant error we
didn't do a lot of observation with
understanding you know how quickly could
people write these things down to record
them but just in our observation process
we observed a lot of communication error
and so that may even Trump this kind of
input error but you're right in saying
that there may be a different class of
errors with this technology for example
if someone brings up an aid but it's the
wrong aid does that lead people down the
wrong path and respect to inputs I guess
the hope is that if you can make it more
visible you can then service some of
these errors so the difficulty with
communication errors is that it's just
into the air and it's not necessary to
specific people or
to getting logs somewhere so if instead
when the nurse is doing input or logging
it then gets shown under the big display
the doctor can kind of double-check that
so I guess the whole principle is to
kind of surface and make visible those
possible errors yeah but we don't have
much time left so I guess wrap up that's
the video link for the sketch of how you
might work with a heads-up display I
just wanted to thank my collaborators so
Jesse the doctors larry inc i'll sue
scott and Pat I'll go really helpfulness
projects and i just opened up for other
questions i won't be i noticed was that
everybody in the room is wearing latex
gloves except the first marine TIFs cuz
i assume it's on pretty easy to work
typo rub some those natural so kind of
tie into that having one person that's
really in charge of work on evade the
same way i do that one person in charge
yeah I media in terms of a clean
environment that's what ends up
happening so it turns out for sample in
to be an anesthesiologist you don't
necessarily have to be as the United
care as much about some of the
sanitation as the person who's actually
you know hands on the patient so you
were typically resemble through the team
leader maybe you are telling people in
drug inject drugs tell people to do CPR
so it's okay if you're not wearing latex
gloves so actually turns out that you
can buy kind of plastic bags for your
iPad which you can get for these
situations where they're just disposable
unless you work through that but yeah I
guess keep I just met
I was kind of simulating yours coming to
this emergency and you're probably not
going to have the gloves you not in the
operation in here regularly simulation
and I wasn't the mother it was an
individual that you're assessing or if
there was a group and how many where
there is a team of one or a team of more
how many teams you had in whether you
saw a lot of variation across teams in
the way they use the aids or the paper
so for this thing we just of the
individuals and about 30 ish and they
had to experience range from med
students to residents and fellows so the
people with more experience tended to do
better home and there was arranged in
terms of who used the AIDS so one fellow
said you know I you know I don't need
these aids and so they put them behind
them and just kind of refuse to use the
paper aids and some people kind of will
always be holding on to that I'm kind of
using them a lot so there was kind of a
wide range of how people use the aids
and that kind of matched holy observed
in the simulation you know so let me
like 10 people for for technology type
so we did a within-subjects the science
of a each person there's three different
scenarios and each participant was
exposed to fit all three conditions in
some order there's any relationship to
use to the aid and individual
performance so you might choose not to
use the aid because in fact you have
done exactly this 5,000 times and you're
correct and assessing that you don't
need it or you could not use the aid
because you're too arrogant to or
whatever unhelpful reason could you
could you look at whether there was any
relationship that people who use the
AIDS do better or it may no effect could
you see anything putting that
right now so we just coated it and we're
analyzing that now so we tracked how
often people would look and refer to the
AIDS and people actually looked at the
digital aids a lot but word right now
still analyzing for example does the
subset that uses aids in general do
better yeah there are maybe lots of
different compounds in terms of
experience level and exposure to AIDS or
definitely trying to analyze the effect
of whether or not people choose to use
these aids never enjoy the presentation
thank you um this is tended in the
setting of crisis management for music
the dramatic moments when you need
studies and reporters and hospitals that
lead to tens or hundreds of thousands of
Devon here it's commonly in the mundane
or daily thing ordering with a
medication or something on a routine
basis sometimes wondering if you've
thought about your group has thought
about application of these aids and
devices for the non crisis situation
look for the mundane situation and
looking at outcome measures and that
setting as well I think it's an
interesting suggestion to try kind of
port back some of these results because
it may be that's you know in the sense
that if you're starting multiple people
in billable services you can then inform
kind of less critical tasks perhaps by
studying this emergency domain in
medicine under time constraints you can
then design it for kind of more routine
care situation so in the situations you
might expect that if they're so stressed
and they still don't have a lot of time
but it's kind of a different level of
stress and different level time
constraint and I would imagine that some
of the insights would still be useful
for example having multiple displays
having things where information is
visible and also having kind of
intelligence information subsets and
kind of useful visual design and sew
something where I think you know in
saying there's a lot of work that needs
to be done in terms of visual
information design and also interaction
design and we're hoping with some of
this work is to show the importance of
kind of visual information and
interaction design so that in these
situations where you can really quickly
assess the impacts then you can then go
back and say okay now for putting in
central lines or for you know drug
dosing if you do this in simulation or
in practice does it actually lead to
measurably different outcomes so it's
something where hopefully this stuff
will get out there rushy talking with
some companies that are trying to get
displacing the hospitals and they're
kind of interested in getting this kind
of content out there so I'm Jennifer duh
I'll completely eliminate doctors from
this situation because it's good
anything about having an automated and
not automated system and how close will
get to that so for some things like be
fit it's clearly there's a standard
system for dealing with v-fib you don't
really need a doctor you just need a
machine to plugging the drugs in shock
at the right moment but then you get a
little more complicated things baby turn
off the automatic system and so be voted
up be able switch the system between
automatic with the doctor and a whole
variety first nah nah nah it's that
major seem to think about this automated
I'm anything so one Commission where
this comes up is if you look
specifically for example at differing a
lot of the doctors don't necessarily set
the right mode for the dipper glitter
and it's something where the instructors
will say something like oh you should be
able to tell the EKG rhythm without
using the machine because you can do it
faster so this is kind of tension
between having the doctors judgment
which is kind of really fast and
informed my judgment versus the
automated approaches which have the
additions advantages of sometimes being
slower sometimes being morbid old
and also you know not necessarily
exposing their state so one thing one
thing people run into is having alarms
which keep on going and I think it
that's the situation where people have
already tried to do a lot of automation
where people will have automated alarms
and then butters inevitably just end up
turning off that like turn that off that
alarm so I think it's something where
you kind of have to really be careful
about putting all your eggs in the
automation basket because it's very easy
for those kind of brittle systems to go
off their own wrong path and start
alarming and with automating input one
of the big challenges is Ashley be
sensing so because the alarms don't
necessarily know the provenance or the
quality of the data they alarm anyway
right so that if their monitors don't
necessarily know that it's not connected
to the patient or that's its
misconfigured so I think there's
definitely a lot of these challenges
which need to be addressed and I think
once sensing technology gets better I
think that is when a lot of the Edit
automation will start happening more
often oh ha Jin my lesson so Eddie you
made a really great acceptance people
being tentative sailors lives and many
will also make offers more accountable
because your age and things off you can
say that you're doing yeah
see that as we go back because I about
this more great I mean some vouchers
will say that if you're designing this
system you want to design it what did
they say they want to know like where
are things which is important for
doctors is like how do they get paid
obviously right so if you can preserve
all ties is system into the billing so
then the doctor can say you must use
this checklist and you can then
demonstrate that you perform the
procedure then you get aid or even from
my accountability perspective you can go
back and look no did you do the right
thing which is also a double-edged sword
so if you do the wrong thing maybe you
want to delete the data or you just
don't want to save it so I think it's
gave it gets complicated but I think
definitely one of the important truths
that are not people believe in or
there's these beside about kind of what
what you do with checklists and one
thing which i haven't seen people pose
but i think is important is that it
would be great if checklists we're not
only interactive but essentially
recorded your data to the government so
it turns out that's so we all know that
healthcare in the US is really expensive
and not necessarily effective but turns
out that there's a subset of medicine
and healthcare which is really effective
and that's the army answer turns out
that because army hospitals and although
doctors record and report their data
they can actually do science and iterate
and so in my vision of the world you
have these interactive to check my
software deployed and you know perhaps
they are anonymized but if you can then
track you know what gets done and the
outcome that would be nobly valuable for
medical research because right now you
may be the individual hospital those or
the chain nose but it's not only
aggregated in the same way that's for
example aviation doesn't so there is no
authority which collects all important
medical errors and then does analysis to
improve that
or medicine what do you think that the
next best thing that you can do without
about men to know because you can okay
the comments as well so if you better do
some things which we do maybe some kind
of smaller hospital or said hospitals
that says okay we're going to about this
technology so we talked with there's
some people building all bajaj bottles
in India or maybe a specific set of
hospitals in the US where they say you
know we're going to adopt this and we're
going to show that this actually has a
clinically important difference and then
I think with medicine that's something
where if you can it can be slow to
change but once the right people get on
board and certain people will decide it
kind of changes very quickly so if
hopefully if you can kind of start small
and show some of these differences then
that'll kind of propagate no Marley how
well do medical devices interface with
each other there's some standardized
output like XML or JSON or something
like how technically challenging if it's
do something see me a simple like
displaying all the output of every
medical advice on the web stream I think
that's usually kind of a big
interoperability challenge from what I
understand um I know that there's a lot
of work now in understanding the
security of wireless mobile health
devices and there are some work at
Harvard looking specifically at
standardizing emrs but as far as sensing
I don't know if people are trying to
build like the USB of medical sensing
but that would be useful I currently
don't know the state of that in practice
I guess the hope would be if you have
some kind of central place where the
data gets into then that would kind of
be one step so if you're for example
epic or practice fusion and you say
that's okay you're all going to
communicate with me in this way no
presumably
10 or 20 years you'll be able to get
that data first that is if you have any
hardware you want even harder the
director said what was your take I guess
that's a very broad question I guess
when it comes to check lists or
cognitive aids I think you know
something with sensing would be pretty
important so being able to tell what
doctors are in the room are doing and
saying I think could probably drive
innovation as to what has been going on
and so if example I guess maybe my
answer would be hired wants a black box
for medicine so in aviation all plans
must have a black box so that when they
go down they investigate it so it would
be I wants a mandatory black box for
medicine where it records in some
privacy conscious way what goes on and
then if something does go wrong or even
if it also lets go right then it kind of
reports back to the hospital to some
bigger institution just so that this
kind of evidence based medicine actually
is what people end up doing might be
kind of output the straight stuff is
good enough so in situ broad cases for
what for when checklist are so what is
the very very common case where you have
this very long way
miss something that little cascaded with
big problem that i got over over
confident that I know what I'm do in
another case is a situation where some
year too often all the rails into a
world that I must know it with this like
the plane is on its way down that
checklist but you do because it is the
best way to help you get through it do
you have a sense of you if you agree
with that typology which is the choose
going to be officially medicine it's a
good question I think there's a comment
about this little bit earlier I think if
you argue that some of these errors
compounds then you want to catch them
earlier and so you could catch them like
as your brother Sokka patient but if you
for example realize that the patient had
a latex allergy earlier then that
they're one of happens so I basically
say that in terms of impact it's a
strange thing in medicine where a lot of
the funding and attention understandably
goes to the last minutes and days and
hours but the kind of earlier you get a
lot of the process like for surgery
starts or even before the patient is
there so for example there's a movement
to do patient-centered checklists not
only for the hospital but you know kind
of your life so like like I check into
meditating every day and so it's
something where you can have checklists
kind of back propagate into how people
live their lives i think the further you
go back there through the kind of
greater the cost savings but the harder
it is to invest in and the longer takes
to evaluate so it may end up being that
you start at this crisis tail end so
things which take like we've kind of
turned over really quickly so like you
know central line infection you can
probably technically quickly or things
which are an order of like hours or days
and then you take that and you're kind
of back propagated to more routine and
then everyday life
so far Chris
any other questions okay
you